you're the experienced married person
what is something that happens like five
years down the line you get two hungry
man dinners and then you watch
Spider-Man
[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
we brought a woman hey woman
uh it's almost Valentine's Day
no a lot of us you know what I mean we
gotta figure out some [__] out I'm
running out of ideas thanks for
reminding me
where are you at right now with ideas
dude absolutely [__] square zero I
got you bro but the thing is I got like
you know we just [__] had Christmas
she's got a birthday next week I got too
much [__] Valentine's a whole other Joe
got an idea that I feel like you're not
down to dude
all right check this the rule is you
have to say yes only yeah you got to do
whatever Joe's about five check this out
[__] no yes this is gonna this is gonna
change your relationship because she's
gonna love you so much okay next level
dog
as you know during Christmas
um Hannah saw like that all I wanted was
a paddle board so she got me a paddle
board right guess what I got her
jack [__] bro and that's how you show
the love Yeah man go like hey
so I gotta say yes
so so it's like what you gotta do all
right so Nina's a bull right you gotta
pull up that red cake and she runs
toward it and then you [__] go Tada
[__] and then there's nothing there and
that's what you gotta you gotta spice it
up is what I'm saying is you gotta
change it up so then they don't expect
what's gonna happen next and then so
she's mad at you right and she's all
like I thought this was gonna be like
our special Valentine's Day and all this
[__]
wait till the next month and then you
March 14th
holiday
you do it
drink dude yeah I think you should do it
it works but then yes but then what are
you doing absolutely yeah
you bought yourself some time so that's
not important just wait all right so
we'll brainstorm the perfect gift for
her this is a setup Joe's the setup I
don't think I'd ever take your advice
well I think I'm just lucky that someone
tolerates me and loves me okay wait you
don't think the delayed gratification
works you don't think that's a good
thing I think if like he was doing it as
a misdirection to like just set the bar
super low so that way you can like hit
it out of the park yeah I mean maybe
that might make a little more sense to
me but like just to do absolutely
nothing yeah it's called a 30-day home
run yeah no it's not nothing it's Tada
[__]
that really gets me going and then later
what happens yeah
it's the 14th of the month she turns
around
yeah exactly what would you recommend
for dudes that have no ideas yeah I'm
out of ideas almost out of time what's
her interests
that's a good question
I never thought about that damn so I
gotta get to know her whoa all right hey
she's in the medical field right this is
a riddle get her some scrubs dude she's
in the Middle Field all right generous
stethoscope and some scrubs we're the
Philippines
is there like a restaurant or a place
that she's been wanting to go or like
maybe she like mentioned something not
scrubs they're gonna be scrubs an
experience that she wanted to go to is
or just [__] just do scrubs so I've
already got it I've gone through scrubs
before actually even for Christmas I
finally got because it was the first
time ever I got her scrub that had been
embroidered uh Dr Nina Lee oh slash L is
the whole thing yeah that's that's cool
we're ordering it just says scrub yeah
so now that one's out the window can't
do that [__] again
I have something kind of smart yeah yeah
but I must what's let's start with her
uh love language
oh Bart's [__] wrong maybe it's not
possessions maybe you don't want that
it's Tagalog
oh my God yeah
that's a good question is there an
experience or something that she's been
wanting to do
uh food always works really well for her
like really nice food nice restaurant
nice new experience
I can cook very man make adobo what if
you guys took like a cooking class
together
experience together that sounds kind of
funny is that like something that people
do on Valentine's Day I'm sure there is
I think so or the day there's there's a
lot of like couples art class couples
cooking classes yeah we should be like
what are you trying to tell me that'll
[__] cook enough for you
yeah uh nah but that'd be funny I don't
know I just think I just think
surprising her is better boys want to do
this one of those [__] little Pottery
things with her hey that's cool yeah
cool clay yeah and watch ghost before
yes yeah I said after he's overboard
whatever you want an experience
something that you guys can do together
it's a memory and then um you know you
guys learn a skill that's sweet not
going to take home though no memorabilia
other than the pot The pot's Good the
possible dude especially if it sucks but
the memories are not enough anything I
think you'd be really good at making a
nice pop making a good pot I think you
could make a [__] sweet Pop I bet you
I make a pretty solid pot you know what
I mean I think you got that I think you
got the vision in the worst case you
know it'll turn into like a dish
I think it has a position
why don't you why don't you guys try
making a pot hide something really cool
in the pot so that when you [__] it up
and it falls apart
we should be asking Ryan Ryan has all
these elaborate ideas Ryan's really good
mine are better for like for gay people
have to die at the end of the day you
know what I mean you know come up with
something here we go I know something
that you guys might like [__] monkey
so you guys just got married right I
think for from a chick's point of view
there's probably nothing more sweet than
really leaning into that so whatever
stuff that people would do when they're
married when they're five or ten years
in plan something like that where it
really feels like we're really married
like having divorce papers ready yeah
yeah as a threat no no no
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah always keep
that in your back pocket okay what what
you're the you know experienced a
married person what is something that
happens like five years down the line
you get two hungry man dinners and then
you watch Spider-Man two hungry man
oh what do you mean to get matching toe
socks put those on watch Spider-Man with
hungry men dinners I think women like
backhanded gifts like if you get her
like invisaligned
it's the line
I'm like here's some Crest White Strips
biting into this for a sec I need this
was a mold that's so [__] funny give
me that I got your braces
here's a discount on breast augmentation
yo that's so messed up just bbl's
I like that okay here's the gym
membership I'm still thinking about like
what does a married couple do five years
down the line other than renew your vows
a year later
you're asking the least romantic people
in the room yeah bro I need I I should
be asking questions also like what does
she expect like
hey why don't you do something with that
kite oh [__] is it one of those rainbow
kites with the bow at the end yeah and
then it flies no new Kai wouldn't cut it
I know but like that's part of the
adventure of the day you take her to
maybe a beautiful beach or something
that's a very very sweet thing
you use [__] AI right to
generate whatever your future baby's
gonna look like oh my God
yeah and then they would always be like
super ugly right that's a good deal for
me right now I got [__] right now your
future baby baby I gotta actually write
this [__] down because that's hilarious
oh God here's our divorce paper
yeah I feel like Ryan's the one with
those like very boring and practical
like renew her passport for her
which is something you have to do when
you change your last name in marriage by
the way she's got to do all that [__]
dude hey that's just a pain in the ass
tip just did it and like I kind of feel
bad for for making her do all of it I
felt really well how come none of you
guys changed your last name huh because
Nick Garcia is actually a pretty good
ring to it dude it does Nick Garcia
sounds pretty good actually Nick Garcia
that is nice but I can't do that
you already got you already have a
non-asian sounding name yeah bro I'm
gonna be Mr double down yeah double down
if anything you should you should have
both changed it instead of d-u-n-n it's
d-o-n-e
[Laughter]
it sounds the same maybe we should do
that for about so both of you changed
the names a new name changes
this kid is pretty hot dude whoa what
the [__] is that that's your son bro
don't say that today's video was brought
to you by DraftKings are you ready for
the biggest Sunday in sports draftking
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of Super Bowl 57 has all the
Super Bowl action that you need new
customers can bet just five dollars and
get 200 and free bets instantly plus all
customers can get in on the Super Bowl
57 excitement with DraftKings happy hour
super boosts check the DraftKings
Sportsbook app every day between 6 p.m
to 9pm Eastern Standard Time to see what
prop bet would be boosted so this year
if you guys have been following you
should be excited about the Chiefs
versus the Eagles we got Patrick Mahomes
versus Jalen hurts both are having an
MVP season yep so I'm excited to see one
stack team versus the other yeah but my
home is like an injurer so yeah yeah so
who's gonna win I don't know download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app and use
code off the Record new customers can
five dollars on Super Bowl 57 and get
200 and free bets instantly only at
DraftKings sports book with code off the
Record minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply void in Ohio see the
show notes for details wait how did you
generate that I just combined it with
Nina's face what photo of Nina's face
and why does he look like a plebe this
photo he looks like a
finger let me see what if you guys
produced future K-pop stars and your
your son is gonna be a that's our 14
year old kid yeah so put that on the
baby's body yeah can we get is there any
more of a baby looking thing you should
name him Luna yeah yeah I can't do a
baby thing that's just a younger me oh
you wanna see what your daughter looks
like uh-oh he's gonna be a easy guys
easy okay I'm not gonna say nothing dude
that's crazy
damn she's cute she's pretty this looks
like Julia's sister or something
I think they're both K-Pop Stars it's
crazy what kind of Asian does that look
I would uh straight up Chinese Anthony
and Joe's baby look like oh
[__] hot we have just entered a weird
realm let's do it remind can't unsee
what's about to happen
Joe and Joe and Anthony's baby
as we try to find a Valentine's gift for
Nina
let's do it let's do it I just put up
like uh AI generated baby of all of us
and I'm like which one do you think is
ours Nina and it's like this is me and
Nick's me and Bart's music
that's good hey out of YouTube who's
been in the relationship longer probably
Bart
in the relationship 2008 how long have
you been Rich 2010 oh yeah but we're
like We're Young though bro
he's he's the he's one of the he's one
of his brothers he's one of the brothers
he does look a little more Japanese
Anthony if Anthony and Jill had a son if
that's low yo that's if if Anthony was
Japanese yeah
yeah that's Japan yeah that's [__]
J-pop the other one was K-pop yeah the
other one did look Korean this is where
ideas go to die yeah JK news maybe not
okay
yeah we're trying we're talking over
here
in your guys's relationship keep it
blank when did you start getting lazy in
your Valentine's Day almost immediately
dude almost immediately what did you did
you start getting late dude that's true
first or second year it's like you try
to knock it out of the park every time
yeah you got five once you realize who's
this
that's you and him combined I feel like
I know someone that looks like oh my god
dude that's Shane Chi bro I know someone
that looks like this that looks like
SEMA I know somebody no that there's
somebody that looks like that it's an
uglier
who's this ugly mouth that's SEMA dude
you [__] I don't agree with that but
it does doesn't it look like it does it
it's funny that it's it's just their
faces together he goes who's that ugly
[__] he's the one called him
ugly I didn't say he's ugly
it looks like he smelled Kaka
it does oh is there any uh Physical
Therapy devices that she needs physical
therapy or like occupational therapy
like a vibrating tool
personal massager
they don't care about stuff like that oh
anything that's too like for their job I
think is too logical
that's not true he already tried it
[Laughter]
so like if the dude you were dating like
dropped his pants and there's just a
nice ass lens
Canon 45.5 I don't know I don't know the
long ones that those perverts yeah Canon
2470. a major one for freaking Kappa
bars
on Valentine's Day
if you got like an experience versus
some new lights
experience see that's what I'm saying
maybe for a birthday or oh
what are you talking about here you
could get a helicopter right I think
it's like 200 bucks but they give you a
helicopter ride and then they take you
down at the Grand Canyon and they have a
lunch set up and then they have like a
little sandwich have you looked into
that there's one that goes to Catalina
that's really nice yeah okay I should
have started this with low budget ideas
it's only like 280 bucks yeah it's like
200 bucks I have another I have another
idea this is under 50 bucks under 50.50
under 50 bucks what is it two eggs the
whole theme is had I Met You in high
school
so you dressed the way you would address
in high school she dresses that way and
you take her on your ideal date in Sunny
Hills oh boy that's cute
what it would have been like if you guys
were together had you guys been 15 or
16. that's cute the day is a disaster
yeah it could be
you know what I think I have someone
with a Civic you can [__] pick her up
all right use my shipping dude oh yeah
you can pick her up in the Lord shots
Ryan Civic in high school dude oh my God
I got a [__] four-door white DX you
had a Civic yeah okay but it was my
sister's hand me down that's like the
most lowest and regular stock Civics not
cool what do you think she's gonna do
for you let me see
um I don't expect anything isn't that
interesting like how like men have to do
something before women I've always said
Valentine's is a girl young yeah
Valentine's I just that is bolo no girls
ever done anything for you for
Valentine's Day I mean it's always like
like sweet stuff I remember one of my
first Valentine's Day gifts ever was uh
oh my God this is so funny that you just
brought that up I can't believe I
[__] remember one of my first
girlfriends gave me this little really
small box and we were like 13 14. and
she's like you remember when you would
like take those thin strips of paper
like colored ones and you'd fold those
little stars yeah yeah so should I fill
this box with all those Stars there's
like hundreds of them right but then
inside
[__] she gave me a pair of panties
yo that's a power play bro it was crazy
stuff for our guys on Valentine's Day
yeah especially at like age 14 too I
remember being like it's crazy I think I
had like a bone of red whales dude
that's fine did you fart and then she
ghosted him no
she got Japan and then she goes who the
[__] is
she's like I took him off for this guy
what if your mom found it and you're
like she's like are you cross-dressing
that's amazing how your mind went there
that's amazing yo I like that idea
though that's right had you guys met at
high school right yeah because my idea
would have been if we met in high school
she'd be in Elementary School wait what
what does that mean the age difference
what does that mean
oh man oh you could have her stand
outside of her Elementary School
we have nothing in common I'm like
[__] babysitting the whole day
stranger danger she's just [__]
trying to talk to me about this monkey
that pissed in its mouth uh six and a
half seven years okay
still if it was a high school elementary
school yes some of us are not trying to
go into that natural place
some of us understand the concept of the
assignment the food still works that's
good you gotta set the correct time
machine okay just just make it uh if I
met you third year of Community College
if I met you when you were legal if I
got held back a bunch
I'm a super senior
super duper scene
and she's a smart guy yeah smart guy
that's better she's a smart guy I'm just
gonna show her this video and get her
some scrubs
I'm over it
I think Bart's idea is really good
though so pick her up from elementary
school take her to the library
[Laughter]
just fill your car with fruit snacks
dude what would it be if you did do
babysitting her the whole time what were
the elements from your high school life
that you would use from high school life
do they gonna translate to hers uh I
remember there was just like you know in
um yeah [__] what was it I think it's
called like orange chill there was a
restaurant on top of the hill that like
I've been to Orange Hill it's beautiful
yeah it's great and I remember that
would be a thing that people would talk
about in high school because we're I was
at Sunny Hills in Fullerton area
um so you go up to the hill just have a
nice dinner that overlooks the city and
stuff like that at night time yeah so
that might have been that's a high
school thing uh I think I think there
was always something fun about being on
campus after like at night like when
it's dark and nobody else is there and
just kind of like running around and
just doing [__] yeah you guys gonna
break into the school and run around
you're just scam in the parking lot dude
yeah there's that take her to make out
Point [__] in the parking lot why do you
say [__] dude I said make out keep it
like keep it chill dude okay yeah she's
in elementary school dude
he won't let you leave that mindset
don't forget all right